back here from the worldwide leader in
sports from espn from first take from
sportscenter
uh former nba champion uh kendrick
perkins here on the rich eisen show how
are you sir
what's going on fellas how y'all doing i
appreciate y'all having me back
of course of course this is the gonna be
the second of many as far as i'm
concerned
so um let's get into it uh kendrick
which
which team did you see from the first
weekend and then maybe
uh the the first full week of the
playoffs
let's start with the one that that
surprised you the most
which one is that kendrick
you know what i mean i'ma say this that
surprised
a lot of people but didn't surprise me
is the memphis grizzlies right
uh i've been how john murray and the
memphis grizzlies i i've been
watching them for a long time uh
and and what they're doing right now is
is
is is just a beautiful thing to see
right you're looking at a a at a group
of
young guys and like my grandmother used
to say
they got old souls baby they just got
old souls and that's how they play
they play with a certain type of
tenacity they act like they
they play like they're seasoned vets
like they've been here before they never
get rattled
and watching them play and watching
their journey
and having to make the play-in
tournament uh
you know lose to golden state then
having to go and play
san antonio and beating san antonio
flying back to golden state
and having to go have a hard-fought game
that win the overtime and john moran and
dylan brooks
stepped up tremendously and and their
coach
doing great things like just think about
this right
a lot of people don't give
a coach a a ton of credit
and i and i feel like you look at that
golden state game it was about four
plays that he could have challenged and
he didn't he just
and i felt like it was a great thing
because he tested the character
of his team and it turned out well for
him
and i think it helped them that's why
they went to utah and went
in one game one and i feel like this
team is playing with a lot of confidence
and i actually got them picked to beat
the utah jazz
this team is fun and electrifying and i
i just haven't seen a saw a young corps
like this
really since the oklahoma city thunder
when they pushed the
los angeles lakers i think to game six
of game
seven but back when russell westbrook
and kevin durant and james harden were
babies
so then one i was gonna ask you which
team is in the the most trouble and
concerns you
uh then i guess maybe i have my answer
in the utah jazz
even though donovan mitchell didn't play
in game one
we did hear that he was pissed about not
playing in game one
and that um and he's going to be back
for game two
would you say the jazz are the team that
concerned you the most
or you want to throw somebody else in
that mix kendrick perkins well
you you know what i'm gonna say it's
about the utah jazz right i know they
had the best record in the league
but to be honest a lot of a lot of
people don't have them winning the
championship right
we wouldn't be surprised if they make it
to the finals because
the west is wide open so to be honest
i mean unless you're a jazz fan
and and and and memphis beat them i mean
it would be an
upset because it's a 1hc but nobody
would really be
shocked and not not me personally i
think right
now the team that's in the biggest
that's in trouble
is the los angeles clippers and
and i say that because when i watch the
way that the dallas mavericks are
playing against them
they playing with a chip on their
shoulder and it started
and it was instigated by the clippers
towards the end of the season well it
actually started in the bubble last year
but it didn't it carried on because
the clippers lost their last two games
to
face the dallas mavericks in the first
round
and the way that the dallas mavericks
came on game one
talking noise swagged up in the staples
center
and the way that they beat them i'm
looking at it like the clippers have got
their hands full
they got to be really really careful and
they better come out in this game too
like it's a game seven like there's no
tomorrow because
if they lose this game tonight dallas is
going to
win this series what else the clippers
what is up with that i mean we you know
i know they were up 3-1 in the bubble
last year before it all
caved in again um you know kawhi
um does he have that chip it doesn't
seem like he does have that chip
although you never see a chip he's won
two chips
um but they're waiting to see it here in
los angeles certainly with the lakers
having won last year what do you think
is up with the clippers what's missing
you know what
to me you know how they could say
having like sometimes having too much
could hurt you and i feel like that's
what's happening with the clippers right
now
they have too much like you you you
you you only could play eight or nine
guys
and when you look at their depth and
they kept adding pieces
it's like who you going to play are you
going to play reggie jackson are you
going to play
rondo you're going to play patrick
beverly are you going to play nicholas
platoon
are you going to play you're going to
get a majority of the minutes of
marcus morris probably marcus morrison
you just gave him a big payday right
are you who who's going to be your two
bigs out of the three bigs you got is it
gonna be
zubac and the doctor or is it gonna be
big cousin stone in the mix somewhere
like
it's just too much that that i feel like
tyloo have to deal with and then on top
of that
i don't think kawhi is healthy right
he's battling through nicks and bruises
and then on top of that where's paul
george right paul george came out he
said hey
people are going to pay this year people
go pay
i'm coming out yo he came out early in
the regular season as usual
but now this is the time where it
matters the most
and again paul joyce shine away from the
moment
and when i say shine away from the
moment i don't
i like if paul george don't score 30
points i'm okay with that
but paul george is also labeled as the
elite defender
and when you have a guy that's 6768
like luca who has the ball in his hands
i'm expecting paul
george to step up to the plate and say i
got him
that's what i'm expecting but i'm not
saying that so i'm like
okay sooner or later something got to
give with the clippers because
it ain't the coaching right you get rid
of doc rivers and you you have ty lou
ty luis is a is a protege of doc rivers
doc rivers raised tyler
in the coaching game so it ain't the
coaching
it's the it's it's it's the fight like
nobody's going to back down from you
guys
nobody cared that kawhi leonard dunked
on cleveland y'all went stood over them
and yelled in it
and stared them down like nobody gives a
damn
the dallas mavericks don't they still
beat y'all and you know what cleveland
said
he said guess what i get dunked on 100
times
i'm going to challenge every shot and
that showed me that this dallas maverick
team
is about their life they want their snow
they're not afraid
of embarrassment so the clippers got to
be careful man
kendrick perkins here on the rich eisen
show co-host of the espn hoop streams
as well as uh a a face and voice of
their basketball coverage uh right here
on the rich eisen show
so tonight um this is a question that
informs us as to who you think obviously
is going to make the nba finals when you
hear how i construct the question but it
also may inform us who you think
will not so i can you you can only
choose one team
playing tonight celtics nets lakers sons
mavericks clippers you can only choose
one team that makes the nba finals out
of this
group of six tonight who do you think
who would you choose kendrick perkins
based on that
that small construct that i've given you
here
i'm going with the best defense in the
nba
and the best duo in the nba and that's
the los angeles lakers
and look i told everyone don't panic
relax
we saw this same story last year the
lakers lost game one to portland
everyone was saying portland go
upset them what happened gentlemen sweep
we saw this
we saw it happen in the second round pj
tucker he's
he's locking anthony davis up they are
they gonna have a hard time with james
harden and russell westbrook
what happened gentlemen sweet when
anthony davis and lebron james decides
to turn up
no one could stop them lebron james
averaged 29
10 and 10 throughout the playoffs last
year
anthony davis i believe averaged what 29
or 30 and 14 and some ridiculous numbers
like that he was putting up shaq and
will chamberlain number so
at the end of the day they have the best
defense in the nba
they lost game one phoenix sun has only
scored 99 points
they have the best defense in the nba
and they have the best duo
in my opinion since kobe and shaq so
it's hard for me to go against that los
angeles lakers team i'm gonna have to
ride with them
until somebody proves to me that they're
going to beat them four times in the
series
which i don't see happening so then
let's uh let's pull this
uh strand a little on the nets
um if you choose the lakers there and
that means the nets not
not like we can't see the nets lakers
but again i'm trying to put this in a
little bit of a box to have a
conversation
uh who who would make it out of the east
if not the nets do you buy what were you
seeing in the first two games
for the bucks looks like obviously a
different uh result first two games
against a team that knocked them
out of last year's playoffs and then won
the conference in the heat
um or you think the sixers or somebody
else even
we're seeing how the hawks and knicks
played you you know
the crazy thing about it is that last
year
i went with the miami heat because i
felt like
they were just going to go in and out
goon the milwaukee bucks
and this year all year long i was
rolling with the philadelphia 76ers i
said they're playing the spying
basketball
well coach they know they rose and right
at the last minute before the postseason
started i
switched up on everybody i switched up
and i'm going with the milwaukee bucks
this team is deep
they're not lacking at anything giannis
is a superstar he plays both ends of the
floor
in the addition of true holiday is so
huge
i think people don't realize that he's
the only guy that i've seen
that gets up into kyrie irving and makes
him
uncomfortable and makes and actually
locks him down
so when you look at the milwaukee books
you look at drew holiday you look at
chris milton
those guys the score right but then they
have other guys that are also giving you
buckets you have guys like brian ford
who came in off the bench shooting the
lights out of the ball
last night but then on the back side of
that
you have two rough riders two guys that
come in off the bench that could be
that's gonna be that
that the big brothers to giannis when he
when he feel like he's having a down
moment
there's gonna be those guys who go
getting guys faces but also contribute
on the court
and that's bobby portis who average i
believe around 11 and 8 this season off
the bench
and then you got pj tucker you got brook
lopez anchoring the defense protecting
the realm
they held the miami heat to what under
under 100 points last night and put up
132.
this team everybody talking about the
brooklyn nets and the big three scoring
power
but the milwaukee bucks is the team that
led the league in scoring this year
averaging 120.
so i have the milwaukee books i think
this is their year
to make noise and come out of the
eastern conference they have had they
they down moments in the in the uh
in the playoffs when they lost to
toronto the year kawhi was there
losing to miami last year i think with
the additions that they add
great job by the front office i think
they have the deepest team in the league
they have enough star power
to come out of the eastern conference so
who do you think uh
knocks the sixers out do you think maybe
the hawks of the knicks have a shot i
mean no
no they don't have a chance at all i
actually i actually think
i actually to be honest with you i
actually think
that it's going to be philly
in the books okay in the eastern
conference finals
all right well that would be quite
something that is for sure
uh and before i let you go trey young
starborn right now
what we saw yesterday years yesterday
this is just coming out party it is
this is why i picked the the house to
win in seven
it's because of trey young i mean he's a
four level scorer
uh and and and right now i i feel like
he's going to be
what jamal murray was last year
in the bubble he's going to come out and
pull out
put on a performance i mean he's built
for this right
he's been he's been doing this since he
was at oklahoma
the lights have been shining bright on
him for a while and now he has the
support and cast
to do it he has a clint capela
down there with along with john collins
and then he had bondonovich who was
stretching the floor averaging 17 points
a game
lou lemon pepperloo coming in off the
bench like
he have so many weapons but trey is so
phenomenal
the guy averaged 25 points and nine and
a half assists this year
and then even make the all-star team and
nobody really was talking about it
he gets you 25 in his sleep so i feel
like the knicks just don't have enough
to match up with him
i think he's going to get past the first
round and i think they're
really going to push philly to a game
seven but philly is going to win but
trey young is about to take off in these
playoffs fantastic
kendrick thank you so much uh look for
uh the call from the show again as we
get to the second round i really love
your insight and uh
and uh the way you you put things truly
well i appreciate it i appreciate any
time they all play out
don't be straight i will not be you can
trust that that's for sure thanks for
the call that's kendrick perkins right
here in the ritual hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here